with strict social distancing measures
in place
New York has seen its coronavirus
infection rates low the state has
recorded about a quarter million cases
overall a third of all of those in the
United States Governor Andrew Cuomo says
more testing will be necessary to safely
loosen restrictions you don't know how
many people were infected you don't know
what is happening on the infection rate
spread all you know is the
hospitalization rate so testing will
give you first of all more data on how
fast the infection is spreading and how
fast it's spreading where while
diagnostic tests like this reveal an
active infection blood tests can reveal
who's developed antibodies thought to
offer some immunity for the disease two
recent studies in California suggest
exposure to the corona virus and
therefore immunity may be more
widespread than thought but scientists
caution it's too soon to draw
conclusions it's really important if
we're gonna be making conclusions about
the prevalence in the larger population
that we have to sample that population
without introducing extra bias so while
that study is important we should not
take that as the final word for true
prevalence in our communities New York
has begun ramping up its capacity to be
able to process 40,000 coronavirus tests
per day this week the Department of
Health also began approaching people
outside of grocery stores like this to
randomly collect 3,000 blood sample
and test them for antibodies in the rush
to do more testing the accuracy of some
brands has been called into question and
experts from the World Health
Organization as well as the Trump
administration say the antibodies
themselves need further testing nobody
is sure but there's someone with
antibodies is fully protected against
having the disease are being exposed
again plus some of the tests have issues
of sensitivity they may give a false
negative result but as the economic cost
of fighting the disease continues to
mount state authorities are under
enormous pressure to find a pathway out
of the lockdown as safely and as quickly
as possible
Kristin salumi al Jazeera New York